ciao ragazzi bentornati a un nuovo video
qui sul mio canale oggi ho pensato di
fare un esperimento ed è un esperimento
sportivo ho pensato di trascinare
all'interno di questa esperienza i miei
fratelli e luigi che io voglio vedere
alle prese con uno sport un pochino
alternativo sto parlando della pole
dance
[Musica]
è partito io pure voglio partire via
d'acqua principalmente io faccio la
parte dei tricks e delle combinazioni al
palo sia stata di crispin bellissimo ma
domani c'è perché io vedo la linea che a
volte sembra che è stata malmenata
pesantemente picchiato
[Musica]
salire sul palo non è come salire
sull'albero c'è una tecnica folle è
impossibile per falso chi lo lancia
subito sotto la manica per ragazzi
[Musica]
aspettami sta aspettando di farlo
beh famiglie rom lo fai te mi aspetta
gas credo che sia questo e paolo che
forse deve usare
a un certo punto pur di scappare mi sono
mimetizzato con l'ambiente
[Risate]
ma io sono una pippa e quindi sono
bravissimi questo modello la stadi che è
un po come fare calista knicks su una
scopa scomodo
questa è uno sport dove si affacciano
tutti i tipi di persone anche quelle che
non hanno mai fatto nulla e quindi deve
andare per gradi non può iniziare anche
una persona che comunque sia un
background sportivo importante come la
ballerina un atleta di ginnastica
artistica con così a si trova uno
strumento non ha mai usato lavora con
uno strumento origin verticale mamma era
già ha veramente
[Applauso]
si sta tirando indietro e quindi
ma
ciao detto turno e mi raccomando
perché siamo col dance
io perché l'ho iniziata per caso per
puro caso perché iniziato a insegnare
danza in questa scuola
io non volevo farla mi ha convinto
simona la scuola si chiama vertical
dolls è un brand
abbiamo tante sedi su roma e altre sedi
in tutta italia anche delle sedi
all'estero quindi è un franchising a
tutti gli effetti donne il 90 per cento
il 10 per cento ti potrei dire uomini
vogliamo pure se la cavava forse deve fa
un po di stretching a guglielmo finché
possibile invece luigi ancora di gesù
ritmo assolutamente guglielmo era
lanciatissimo si muove pure bene
si no
mi guardo attorno il deserto gabriele
che secondo me è un jet lag di 7 minuti
cioè lui continua a fare i passi dei
sette minuti prima poi abbiamo gianluigi
si attacca al palo ma il suo palo è
attaccato alla corrente perché ha delle
specie di spasmi quel non lo comprendo a
parigi decisivo a lavorare come
convinzione come condizione di re luigi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
numeri
diciamo che è una disciplina che ti
spinge uscire abbastanza dalla tua
confort con ti prego via cambiare
dimettersi il fatto che l'unico che
commettere il vai a mettere il tacco da
chi no
in archi colpo
[Risate]
oddio mola
non riesco a muove questo titolo
arrivo
[Musica]
però di nuovo
grazie io non ho fatto sport e per 11
anni questo insieme a tanti altri
problemi quindi sfogli sul cibo che ha
portato anche ad accumulare peso a non
accettare me stessa io ho rifiutato lo
specchio anche prima di entrare in
doccia per dire quando mi dissero
andiamo a provare pole dance io venni
solo per accompagnare un amico ma che
c'è chi mi metto a fare nemmeno faccio
le scale per salire abito al primo piano
arrivo incontro angela subito dico che
però aspetta questa persona mi sta
facendo fare delle cose e ci riesco e
non mi sono sentita troppo brutta uno
sguardo specchio come ero vestita avevo
dei pantaloncini da basket da uomo fino
al ginocchio e una maglietta da uomo con
le mani coni lunghe però sul palo devi
avere la pelle a contatto per molte cose
altrimenti cade ne sono iscritta
iniziato a riandare una volta a
settimana
poi vediamo che miglioravo e piano piano
piano piano andavo sempre a comprarmi
pantaloni sempre più corti per sé
facendo quale prende
insegna
[Musica]
frutto di verde compiuto questo summit
g8
finché dopo praticamente sei mesi che ho
iniziato le mie amiche mi hanno
obbligata letteralmente a spogliarmi
perché comprai un completino ho fatto
apposta da folle sono tipo costumino
però non avevo la minima intenzione di
rimanere con quella ce lo mettiamo sotto
come portafortuna rumor che mi sentivo
che avevo questa cosa sotto niente mi
hanno presa mi hanno bloccato ogni anno
spogliata mi hanno fatta vedere allo
specchio mi ha detto adesso ci devi
spiegare perché tu non ti metti così ti
permette di liberarsi da tutte le sue
paranoie sul tuo corpo e piano piano ci
riesce ho cambiato il punto di vista nel
guardare il mio corpo cioè non lo
giudico più in base alla bellezza ma la
funzionalità e questo mi permette di
venire a lezione con un sorriso pazzesco
io mi spoglio non vedo l'ora di
spogliarmi per fare l'esercizio quindi
l'approccio corpo è cambiato tantissimo
e ci sono riuscito in anni di terapia
quindi non penso sarei riuscita un altro
modo a in così poco tempo in un anno a
cambiare completamente
come vede come vedo me stessa e allora
la mia passione per l'accoglienza è nata
in maniera
strana particolare perché di fatto nasce
da un punto si potrebbe si potrebbe dire
io avevo una nonna
chiamavo tantissimo e che mi manca tanto
adesso è lei purtroppo per problemi
fisici dovuti ovviamente all'età non
riusciva più a muoversi come come
avrebbe voluto
qualche volta in televisione passava che
ne so il cirque du soleil
quindi questi acrobati bellissimi e lei
diceva che bello quanto mi piacerebbe
poterne fare queste cose io ormai ho
fatto fatto il mio tempo non mi posso
più muovere ma tu perché perché tu non
ci provi perché sarebbe bellissimo
sarebbe bellissimo per articolare così e
quindi quando purtroppo le è venuto a
mancare sono decisa a fare questa cosa
ea superare anche un po questi limiti
per esempio nel mio caso della la paura
dell'altezza la paura di stare a testa
in giù io non mi sono mai arrampicata
nemmeno su un albero per dire e adesso
mi arrampico a tre metri e venti di
altezza
sono molto felice mi sembra di aver
fatto anche un regalo non solo a me
stessa ma anche a mia nonna che sono
convinta che mi guardi sia felice per me
[Applauso]
le passioni secondo me hanno il potere
veramente di curarci una delle cose che
questa esperienza mi ha ricordato è che
effettivamente siamo troppo abituati a
pensare veramente dalla copertina di
aver letto tutto contro il libro provare
nuove cose non è solamente un modo per
tenersi occupati ma anche un modo per
scoprire nuovi aspetti di noi veramente
credo che il mondo non mi da allora di
stupirci e che l'unica cosa che dobbiamo
fare è veramente uscire di casa
io come sempre vi lascio tutti quanti i
link delle persone che mi hanno aiutato
e che sono state disponibili e per la
realizzazione di questo video che invito
a seguire questo canale attivare la
campagna delle notifiche ma soprattutto
in questo caso se non mi rompe farmi
sapere che cosa ne pensate di un format
di questo tipo
se avete dei suggerimenti in che cosa vi
piacerebbe vederci coinvolti a me e alla
mia famiglia
vi ringrazio di cuore ancora perché
siamo vicinissimi a questo milione per
me ha così tanti zeri che non riesco
nemmeno a vederli tutti quanti insieme
così a botta d'occhio e che dire ci
vediamo la prossima volta che ancora
sarà una grande incognita perché non so
che cosa faremo mai
all esperimento che voglio portare
avanti ed è un modo per insomma
cimentarsi in nuovi contenuti e cercare
un pochino di rendere questa piattaforma
sempre più diversa e nuova
fino ad allora vi auguro una buona
giornata e che dire ci vediamo la
prossima volta con un prossimo con un
prossimo video massimamente se un brano
che ha giurato bene a socchiudere basta
finiamo così ciao